well before we get into the more
important discussion I have to say that
I'm still marveling at this thing with
Elizabeth Warren ben shapiro wrote
something yesterday where he said that
trumps superpower is that he gets his
opponents to say stupid things and do
stupid things which is a great
superpower to have especially as we head
into the midterms and certainly to
release your DNA results to prove that
your great-great-great great-great-great
granduncle may have been possibly Native
American or or maybe just Mexican or
Colombian or something well that is a
stupid thing that is a very stupid thing
it's stupid not just because the results
are so sad and they actually disprove
the very thing you're trying to prove
but because this is an embarrassing
subject for Warren and for the Democrats
and it's something that they should be
ignoring you know the right approach for
them was just to act like this
Pocahontas thing wasn't happening to
ignore it completely call it a
distraction anytime the Republicans
bring it up to say oh they're talking
about these silly things because they
don't want to talk about the plan for
America they want to talk about the
economy you know that whole that whole
thing the politicians do but to actually
bring it up yourself I mean that is
astoundingly stupid that this is the
thing you're not supposed to want to
talk about this is the embarrassing
thing for you everyone's laughing at you
and and that's though as a politician
the worst thing the world's to become a
punchline that's the worst thing you
don't want people to laugh at you they
could they could hate you they can be
angry at you Thicke but but for them to
laugh at you and consider you a
punchline I think that's the worst thing
in the world which which by the way for
for for Democrats and for liberals in
their opposition of Trump
by far for them the more effective move
is to make him into a punchline and to
treat him like a cartoon and a
caricature which they which they do that
quite a bit and I think that's far more
effective than but on the other hand
they also mix that in with taking him
very seriously and you know saying well
he's the second coming of Hitler and
he's gonna destroy the world and
everything else that that's like the
opposite of treating him as a punchline
that's taking him very very seriously so
they're doing both things and that it's
the latter the second one that is not
effective it's not an effective strategy
um but it's all it's all part of this
where they kind of can coax them into
doing stupid things and why did she do
this stupid things well this stupid
thing well because this is what happens
when you have blind seething hate in
your heart for somebody else
and I think in any competitive
environment whether it's whether it's
politics or anything else it doesn't
help to be filled with hate and rage you
don't want that because you can't think
clearly in that condition you don't have
the calm cool kind of head that you need
to analyze the situation choose the most
expedient path form a strategy and
execute it that you can't do that when
you're filled with hatred it's like can
think about in football you know if
you're a linebacker on a football team
it helps to play a little bit angry it
helps to be aggressive to get pumped up
to have a little bit of a grudge against
your opponent but you can't be overcome
with hatred for your opponent because
then you get flustered you make dumb
decisions you're not strategic and
you're thinking so when a player is way
too angry and he hates the other team he
hates another play on the other team
they've gotten into his head that's what
he might go and punch a guy in the head
or tackle someone after the whistle
which may be satisfying for him in the
moment but then it detracts from his
overall objective of actually winning
the game because then he gets the
penalty he gives a first down to the
other team
and when it comes to politics I think
Trump's opponents are constantly taking
personal foul penalties there
constantly giving Trump first downs
Trump is marching up and down the field
and because of penalties all the time um
and and it's because they're making
decisions based on sheer hatred not
strategy these are not pragmatic
strategic decisions and in this case I
think Warren the only thing she could
think about the only thing on her mind
was that she wanted to prove Trump wrong
and she wanted to try to make him look
stupid but in the process she just made
herself look stupid
because that's all she could think about
she wasn't she wasn't thinking clearly
now let me say something else um because
this whole warren thing has brought up a
conversation about putting the politics
aside for a minute there's been a
conversation about about when can you
really say that you're part something
everyone likes to claim in America this
is an American thing I'll get to that in
a minute but every what America likes to
claim that there's that they have some
kind of ethnic heritage so people say oh
I'm Italian I'm Irish I'm I'm a Native
American I'm French whatever but when
does it really count
when can you really say it and look let
me just in this just general PSA okay
because we're on the subject here is the
rule I think okay if you if you're off
the boat yourself then obviously that
counts okay so if you're off the boat
from from from France or I guess it'll
be the plane these days then you could
say that you're French if your parents
were off the boat then that counts if
two or more grandparents are off the
boat that counts but here's where it
gets complicated so I think that's all
pretty straightforward right but but but
here's where it gets complicated what if
say only one grandparent just your
paternal grandmother was from Italy can
you then say that you're Italian and
here's how I think we sort through that
okay if it's only one grandparent I
think you can claim that heritage as
your own if you were close with her
growing up and you were around her a lot
and you spent a lot of time with her
because then you have more than just a
trace of Italian DNA because if it's
just if it's just one grant even even
it's even a grandparent if it's just one
grandparent that was from in this
country but you know that's it when it
comes to your actual to the actual you
know in a literal sense the the your
there's there's not much there right
it's pretty diluted but if you're around
her a lot and you're very close with
this Italian grandmother then you have
the heritage you have the customs you
have the culture which you which you
would have absorbed from your Italian
grandma and then I think in that case
it's fair to say well I'm part of time
but if your Italian grandmother died
when you were three and all of your
living relatives and the only ones you
ever spent any time with we're all just
American no accent nothing then you're
American you're not italian-american
you're just your American that's all
you're American which by the way is fine
it's it's great it's awesome this is the
weirdest thing about America is that
everyone wants to live here but nobody
wants to be from here for some reason
everyone wants to claim that they're
from somewhere else well what's wrong
with just being from America if your
family has been here for generations
then you're from America you're not from
Poland you're from America and what's
wrong with that
what's wrong with having American
heritage I mean again if you've been in
this country for generations and almost
all of your family members are from this
country wealth and that's why go around
saying oh I'm 1/4 Irish 1/10 polish a
13th Australian no you're not you're
American none of that means anything
what I mean you're 1/4 Irish 1/4 this a
quarter what is that again unless you
really grew up in a house that was just
immersed in that culture then fine but
if that if you just have a quarter that
doesn't meet your your America that's
what you are and that's the thing with
Warren her family was a parent has
parently been here in America for a very
long time
if she can trace her blood back 300
years to find that potentially someone
in her family reproduced with a Native
American well that means that she that
her family's been here for a very low
for centuries and that's something to be
proud of that is a heritage in and of
itself it's not like you could only have
a heritage if you're from some other
country like we don't have our own
heritage we tweak it you can't have one
from America if your family has been
here since the Civil War or earlier
that's really cool that's awesome you
should be proud of that
stop trying to erase your family history
by homing in on that little fraction of
some other culture that you allegedly
have in your blood but that has really
had very little influence on you or I
should say no influence at all really um
people don't do that in other countries
by the way nobody in China is going well
I'm a quarter Korean a tenth South
African no they're not doing that
they're Chinese and they're proud of it
they're saying I'm Chinese so why not be
American I mean America was it was an
unsettled wild frontier country only 150
years ago America is a very young
country so if your family has been here
for a long time then your family was
here when the country was still being
built and and tamed and formed and
that's awesome that is a heritage that
is history
that is American history American
heritage and you should be proud of it
stop trying to comb through your
ancestry so that you could say well I'm
1/16 Mongolian who cares that doesn't
mean anything this had no no influence
on you whatsoever you are American
period be it all right
switching gears so over the weekend
speaking of Americans American American
pastor Andrew Bronson was released after
two years in a pircuit Turkish a Turkish
prison
had been arrested on charges of
Christianization which yes that is
that's a real thing and in many
countries across the world
Christianisation is a crime that you can
commit and the trumpet administration
negotiated for his release and he
finally arrived home and there was a
wonderful scene at the White House where
pastor Brunson was thanking Trump and
prayed for him prayed over him and was a
great scene but I think I think pastor
Bronson's plights
and as far as I know he hasn't spoken
much yet about about his actual
experiences in prison which I'm sure
we're not pleasant experiences I'm sure
we'll hear that story eventually but his
plight brings our minds back or or or
ought to bring our minds back anyway to
the problem of Christian persecution
across the world
remember he was arrested for being
Christian that was his crime and that is
a crime as I said in many countries in
fact there was a recent report released
a few months ago that said that
Christian persecution today is worse now
than it's ever been in history you know
China Egypt India Iraq Nigerian North
Korea Pakistan Turkey Saudi Arabia the
situation is very bad in all these
countries Christians are arrested
tortured killed
persecuted in many other ways their
churches are burned down
and their their very existence their
faith their existence has been
criminalized there's a story in Newsweek
of all places about this problem a few
months ago may read a little bit of that
to you just to give you the just so you
understand what's happening
it says the persecution and genocide of
Christians across the world is worse
today than quote at any time in history
and Western governments are failing to
stop it a report from a Catholic
organization said the study by aid to
the church in need so the treatment of
Christians has worsened substantially in
the past two years compared with the two
years prior that has grown more violent
than any other period in modern time not
only are Christians more persecuted than
any other faith group but
ever-increasing numbers are experiencing
the very worst forms of persecution the
report said the report examined the
plight of Christians in China Egypt
India Iran Iraq Nigeria North Korea
Pakistan Saudi Arabia Sudan Syria Turkey
over the period lasting from 2015 until
2017 and the research show that in that
time Christian suffered crimes against
humanity some were hanged some were
crucified
it says Saudi Arabia was the only
country where the situation did not get
worse
but that doesn't mean it got any better
the report put a special focus on Middle
Eastern countries like Iraq and Syria
where the authors argued Christians
would have been entirely wiped out if it
weren't for military action and the
assistance of Christian humanitarian
organizations that it talks about the
situation for Coptic Christians in Egypt
and then for Christians and in various
African countries that's very bad as
well so this is a this is a widespread
problem across the globe yet despite
this Newsweek article it gets very
little attention
even though every once in a while you
have a story like the pastor being freed
which got a little bit of attention from
the mainstream media
why is it getting more attention well as
I think I've explained before I think
the main reason well there are two
reasons we don't pay attention that much
to Christian persecution across the
globe the first reason is that it's far
away and it's just hard for us to care
about things that are far away so it's
similar to if there's a if there's a
natural disaster in Indonesia that's not
going to get our attention as much as a
disaster in the Florida Panhandle
because these things are closer to us
and and and to a certain extent you know
into a certain extent that makes sense
it makes sense for us to to care
particularly especially about the things
that are close to us it's a very human
thing it's a very normal thing
[Music]
but when it comes to the persecution of
Christians overseas I think it seems as
though we've we've basically entirely
ignored it
at least the media has like it doesn't
matter at all and that of course is not
okay that's not natural that's not human
and what's the reason for that what's
the special reason for ignoring the
persecution of Christians overseas I
think that um that the reason is that
Christians have been historically and
are today on a massive scale victims
Christians are in a very real sense a
victim group not in every country
certainly but but then there's no group
of people in the world anymore who are
victims in every country okay there
isn't which is a which is a great thing
but there isn't any type of person any
demographic left that is violently
persecuted everywhere across the globe
unborn babies may come the closest to
that designation there are 50 million
abortions across the globe every year so
I think they I think they fall into that
category but among born people that
doesn't really exist which again is
great that's we should celebrate that um
yet the
of Christians is endemic it is an
epidemic maybe it may not be happening
everywhere but it's happening in many
many places
but we don't talk about it because
remember in America victimization is
power everybody wants to be a victim and
the whole point of identity politics
like we talked about yesterday
it's to divide people into two groups
victim and victimizer and the left has
made it very easy for itself and it's
said that basically everyone except for
white Christian males belong in the
victim group
if they acknowledge that actually
Christians Christians of all races and
ethnicities are being persecuted across
the globe
that it throws off their whole system
also I think the left it considers the
victim title to be a great honor to be a
very trendy and kind of cool thing to be
a victim and so they don't want they
don't want to share that title with
Christians because they hate Christians
and indeed on a global scale they would
they would say that Christianity is
perhaps the greatest villain of all
that's the narrative that they've
established and this just interferes
with that narrative
and that's why they tell stories about
the Inquisition and the Crusades because
they have to go back they have to go
back centuries to find even an arguable
or alleged example of Christians
systematically persecuting anyone that's
why they have to immediately you know
they go to the Crusades as a thousand
years ago so that should really tell you
something that when when people want to
make a case that the Christian Church
has been this violent persecutor the the
first thing they do is they go back a
thousand years to the Crusades of course
we could talk about how the Crusades are
misunderstood and they were largely at
least they were originally launched as
defensive struggles against against
Muslim aggression but but even a
sideline even if that is an example and
it was just straightforward the
Christians were evil
and they did terrible things and there
was nothing redeeming about it well that
was a thousand years ago and the fact
that you have to go back a thousand
years that should really tell you
something so but but again there this is
this is all about the narrative and
they're there in their narrative their
entire worldview is really thrown for a
loop if they admit Christians into the
persecuted club they can't do that
because they're their philosophy on life
hinges on this idea of persecution and
victimization and so they've got a very
strict formula and they just can't they
can't fit Christians into the into the
victimized group they can't do it it
ruins everything
and so I think that combined with how
distant all of this is to us
geographically those two things together
just are the two ingredients that are
needed to Khaliq ompletely ignore what
this report I think accurately calls
genocide but you know we we and when I
say we I mean those of us who are not on
the left and who are not Christian
haters we should not ignore it this is
something that we should be paying
attention to thanks everybody for for
listening thanks for watching I'll talk
to you tomorrow
Godspeed
you